[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don shotgun
super excited to be talking about
photography our life-sized portraits of
whales the sun's light and studio cosmos
we have Bryant Austin joining us on the
show hello Allen
thanks so much for coming on thank you
for having me super excited for this
show so I actually had to change one of
you put one of your photographs as my
desktop background because it was so
beautiful the way Li I'm so excited to
be talking about all this with you today
those who don't know Bryan Austin's
background he's a photographer mostly
known for making life-sized portraits of
whales and exploring the sun's light in
ways that revealed the cosmos around and
within us you can find the links in the
bio to Studio cosmos calm as well as
Brian's book beautiful whale and his
Instagram all right Bryan let's start
things off with one of our favorite
questions asked are yes what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world
well I mean gosh you know our direction
is unsustainable we're a tool-making
species so we're doing all kinds of
amazing things but I the short answer is
I don't know but this probably happens
elsewhere in the universe and I think of
the Oakside photograph they released
10,000 acorns and maybe one becomes a
tree maybe there's you know 10,000
acorns in the universe is only one
becomes a self-sustaining conscious form
of life that goes out into the universe
in to understand itself
you know so I don't know it's a big
experiment I don't it doesn't look good
it doesn't look like we may be that
acorn I hope so and
we're in a huge crazy transitional time
right now so we'll see in this a big
difference between being out in the
middle of the ocean with whales and
feeling the sustainability or in the
Redwoods you know versus being in a
metropolis and seeing garbage on the
streets and all this type of stuff so in
wealth inequality these types of things
absolutely so what do you think would be
maybe a strategy for sustainability that
you think could you know really help us
out uh well we have to change our values
like right now you think about the you
know this concept of an economy it it
takes care of our short-term survival
and we focus on our short-term survival
at all income levels and whether it's a
corporate Empire we're always thinking
of our economic survival and that's a
short-term strategy ecological is a
long-term strategy and we just don't
think about it you know so we have to we
have to transcend that and
we can either go back which I don't
think will happen and so we're just
going to get the technology's gonna have
to get better where we have to get more
efficient you know we've got to move
away from all the models we're seeing
right now
you know things being centralized and
scaling up to insane levels just is
highly inefficient it's disempowering I
mean gosh I could spend the hour on that
with you yeah I like the phrase you
prioritize ecology over economics in a
way that's you know sustainable and
because this is do you think that the
majority of the ailments that we have in
our civilization is because of our
disconnection from source from nature
that's a big part of it well you know
yeah absolutely
yeah that's what the indigenous elders
have been teaching us for a while now
they're like connect back to source to
nature yeah if I'm out of balance if I'm
really stressed and like just things
seem really create I just go back and
hrl backpack for three days you know or
or go freediving you know and you know
do some long deep dives and just really
just surrender and reconnect with nature
it's very powerful it's it doesn't seem
like it would do anything to us as we
use words to describe that but when
you're immersed in it it's yes
transformative
in brainless do you journey so who were
you as a kid growing up there got really
interested in photography our expression
that was all dormant so as a kid I was I
was a redhead I was overweight I went to
a new school every two years so I was
constantly in fights getting teased beat
up and so all that stuff that's within
me that that longing to connect with
nature and connect with it as a creative
as an artist was dormant it was did it
barely exist today you know I tried
painting and drawing you know whether
it's comic book you know themed things
or transitioning to nature and and my
late teenage years it just transcended -
or transition to the cosmos painting but
I was never satisfied with it so I
started painting the cosmos yeah just
trying to find ways to reveal it around
us through paint but I had no life
experience I had my experience was so
limited and so I had some really
important mentors in my late teens and
early 20s that were my first real
friends like I didn't know what
friendship was like what's a real friend
like what's a good friend and they were
they profoundly changed my life and like
I realized but there's nothing I can't
do I mean yeah I have one mentor taught
me BASE jumping so so I was never good
at sports so I just thought that's
because I suck as a person I'm less than
human and then to to be introduced to a
sport like that like well I have to be
good at it or I'll die
so I practice and I I mean I practice in
my bedroom on launching and body
positioning like just really just
visualizing and got really good at it
and and that what that was really
empowering yeah because I just thought
you could do anything you want you know
yeah whoa yes so mentors were critical
and yeah and they nudge you in the
direction of really challenging yourself
with be having yeah that was John Boland
I grew up in Sacramento or that's where
we met where I grow
and you know and you know the sad thing
is my mentors died and both Jonathan and
a another guy named Mark Hinkel and it
was really their their passing that
little fire under me it's like they
taught me how to live well and how to
embrace life and follow my truth and I
have to honor that yeah so that's all
I've been doing ever since then those 28
years ago you know yeah Wow yeah embrace
life and follow your truth follow your
truth and now or you'll suffer big-time
yeah yeah so you follow what you've
discovered as your purpose or there will
be suffering that come yeah yeah it's
hard yeah I mean yeah yeah and it's hard
to follow your truth as well yeah
there's gonna be test of faith back
there should be tests yeah challenges
that arise but those are the those are
the important things to see as
challenges to overcome because those are
the tests that are there to see yeah
yeah yeah and and and doing my work but
the wells
you know I sold everything I owned you
know like I sold my car I lived in a
trailer I sold my trailer because I just
put all my money into the practice and I
would think well how do I feel about
that how do I feel about having nothing
and being nomadic basically almost
homeless yeah well I'm still here I
still love Who I am as I come I'm still
practicing my work so I guess I'm good
this old car yeah yeah really went all
out
once I had once it was revealed to me
with well something was real to me
that's completely missing how did you
even get the first taste of whale you
know well that that goes back to my
childhood okay yeah I I saw dolphins at
a marine park in Redwood City back in
the early 70s I didn't know what they
were I didn't know what a dolphin was I
I knew they were I felt that
consciousness from them I was only like
6 years 7 years old and they were
suffering they were in filthy dirty
water you couldn't even see the bottom
of the 4 foot pool covered in scratch
marks kids splashing and screaming and
completely disconnected from their
suffering and it was so evident to me
but I couldn't process it I just buried
it because I my parents were divorcing
and so I was just burying all stuff in
it and then I could you know come out
later easy try to try to understand it
whoa yeah and I it was through my
mentors you know through through really
honestly it was BASE jumping that said
yeah go photograph well that's what I
started
whoa okay but now now take us into Jason
at that part of the journey because I
love some of the sentences on the
website the feeling of
interconnectedness that you portray
through every photograph what that every
photograph taken throughout history is a
self-portrait of the cosmos yeah I love
that yeah you know it's easy to feel
separate it's easy to feel that nature
is separate from us that you and I are
separate but we're all an expression of
one thing you know
and it sounds corny you know to say that
but yeah but nature can sometimes bring
you fully into the present moment and
when you can feel the cosmos right here
I mean just last year I mean real quick
I
that's this transition this chant this
metamorphosis happened we're
photographing the Sun with my telescopes
and watching a shadow come behind me
it's the sun's rising but it's rising
behind a mountain and the mountain
shadow was coming towards me and I can
feel that shadows presence it was almost
a person I was walking towards me and
and as instant I felt the cosmos
experience itself through me until there
was no longer at me and it was it's
really hard to describe
oh yeah you know and it really changed
me that they don't have to describe it
with us
we know yeah it comes and goes now it
comes and goes now but it was really
Susan the mountains shadow was slowly
starting to come up yeah it was it was
Half Dome shadow Half Dome Yosemite and
you can see it come down clay sure point
right but it takes time but once it hits
the valley floor it starts to pick up
speed and and and I would just keep
looking over my shoulder and it was just
you could almost see it moving towards
you and it does you can see it moved
towards you because there was a time I
thought well I'm gonna when that shadow
comes to me the Sun is visible so what
I'll do is pick up my telescope and run
into the shadow and reset up and
recompose this thing I'm working on
there's a trip in photographing for four
years on that it's only a six foot
Jeffrey Pyne but I thought I'll just run
and I realize oh I picked up my
telescope and the shadow is going like
like I can't even ride and now all that
is is Earth's rotation Suns not moving
you think about it you know
and that's just a star you know well son
is yeah moving while the earth moves
around it yeah oh it's moving in its own
direction so direct yeah that's right
yeah yeah yeah you've been photographing
the same tree for four years
there's several trees I've been
photographing for four years so what I
love to do I've done with whales is I
like to go deep in terms of depth of
time with a subject so whether it's a
whale an individual well or a population
a group of whales I like to go deep and
to you know definitely great depth of
time with them
I think you know the thing I do to do
that is I have to emotionally decouple
from all the financial pressure one
feels doing this kind of work so if you
could just separate yourself from that
financial pressure and be willing to
invest the time that's where you start
to see things that most of us will never
see or experience because we're bringing
that pressure of you know the bottom
line to that world
yeah so then if we take ourselves away
from the economic and political
machinery Ferb yeah it's of time that
enable us to go really deep with subject
absolutely especially natural subject
yeah yeah like trees whales Sun stars
sure yeah ourselves in those moments to
those deep yeah yeah that's even harder
yeah deep are you sweet is it pretty
clear to you that we come from creation
that we're all one expression yeah I
mean you know not all the time but like
I have moments where it's so obvious to
me but like you know it comes and goes
it comes and goes it's really hard to
keep it all the time it's elusive yeah
yeah it's like oh yeah you know yeah you
said it was the having the cosmos right
here
and I love ya you know and as yeah yeah
so then it was it started in 2004 and it
went for about 2006 was the first
life-size composite that was my first
portrait the first portrait of the whale
okay yeah and then you've been doing
this for 15 years the whale specifically
for about I've been doing whales for 15
years the life-size part of it has been
about 12 years but honestly it's been 2
years full-time at sea and 10 years
logistics and fundraising and organizing
everything shows fieldwork all that so
yeah it's a lot of work yeah and what
little very little creativity and and
that's why I had to stop wait how is it
little creativity because you you have
to do so much to to get the funding to
be in the field it's very expensive to
be in the field with them yeah yeah and
because I work alone with them yeah if
you work alone they're more likely to
come right up to you
and and the only time when you're making
life-size portraits they have to be 5 or
6 feet away if there are any further
than 6 feet using a telephoto portrait
lens there's just nothing there to make
a life-size portrait you need you need
to get like you can see like we have
wrinkles and all this well yeah Jose
yeah I get all that and you get the skin
peeling off you get the finest details
and that these are all the things that
make them real and photography yeah
and and you make obviously make the
photos life-size so you make the photos
the photos are like injured but no I
haven't done that yet my largest is 8 by
36 feet 36 feet yeah it's in what's in
one of the photos videos I gave you yeah
but that one's never been printed I did
I finished that in 2012 that's that's
one that's been print that's 30 feet I
have one bigger than that a 30 foot
print and that's archival that's it's
all done to archival standards it's
that's in Tokyo Wow but they're very
expensive and there's nothing there's
nothing easy about this work the the
these are very expensive yeah
everything's expensive about it and it's
really important that we see this work
you know yeah and I I've I've done five
shows in Norway a country that hunts
whales and I did a show in Tokyo that's
some detail one of my portraits yeah you
know and I wanted to show the working
countries that hunt whales not to end
whaling but just to see how people
respond and and I thought if I can move
people in these countries where the
issue is so polarized that we're just
like numb to it that there might be hope
that it could be influential in other
countries because it's not whaling
that's doing them in it's it's our
lifestyle all of our lifestyles are
basically doing the oceans in and whales
you know the parts per million of co2
the microplastics microplastic ocean
acidification the shipping industry
being in receive goods from sweatshop
factories that run over wells but most
importantly its commercial fishing
commercial fishing and I think in 2002
there was a conservative estimate of
300,000 whales and dolphins dying in
fishing gear every year and
[Music]
it's probably a lot more than that and
that you know and and yeah so yeah and
then some of the things that I'm
noticing is that you know you even
capture some of the the sun's light on
the ocean surface that is then being ya
displayed on the whale itself yeah I
love that that is gorgeous
at first I wanted overcast because it is
even and I thought because these are all
stitched together there there are
probably 20 photographs in this large
composite yeah now how am I gonna blend
them together and not and not look weird
but I found they blend together
beautifully they do yeah it's really
because you're using like brushstroke
gestures to get rid of the hard edges of
the photographs as you align them and
then you just start to remove more to
blend the light and what's been
wonderful for me too is now working with
the Sun for the last four years and
honestly just
you know that transformation I showed
earlier it's really opened me up to the
infinite nature of sunlight and it's
light ball and earth yes
and seeing it fall on this well right
here like back then this was 2011 I
wasn't really paying attention to that
now it's just like oh my god there
that's just wide open that you could do
just so much with that and so that's one
of the reasons I'm really inspired to go
back this winter Wow
this was like 10 feet away from you 20
feet away from me oh no no maybe six
feet six feet yeah this was actually too
far away when I made some photos during
this event but oh he's too far away she
got really close here how do you know
it's a female
I agree they're genital slit so if it's
a male is just one slit and if it's a
female it has two memory slits on either
side two memories of the general slit
yeah so she's checking me out see
they're nervous too so you can see her
open her mouth that they're just a
threat display so she's just trying to
intimidate me which it works it works
yeah of course it works yeah so even
there I'm too far away but I will not
close the distance she has to do that
she has to close it yeah yeah yeah as
soon as that is because if I close a
distance she may leave she may leave and
be like oh this is what he's all about
and never come back
exactly especially since it's likely
that they've been communicating about
how some of their some members of their
species have potentially been dying due
to human yeah
related yeah cuz this is in this is
incredible Wow Wow
yeah yeah there and still she's too far
away but I just just because we're
trying to get some footage of my work I
just went ahead and went through the
motions but yeah she's way too far away
those would never be life-sized yeah I'm
like yeah you have that distance it's
cool how you were teaching me about the
importance of intent because if the
intent is to go on a quick tour to go
and try and get something it's not gonna
come versus when you go with the intent
of being patient and really expressing
that that notion of of love and and I'm
gonna I'm just here I'm here peacefully
yeah you can come to me and I'll show
you that I'm here peacefully and I'm not
gonna close the gap yeah I'm actually an
interestingly enough a lot of like men
are also starting to not close the gap
in terms of like relationship with women
like enabling the woman to come for and
closer a great space to create space
absolutely oh yeah yeah yeah intent is
so important yeah you know I'll have
people that you know are spiritual and
new-age and all that and they ask me if
I communicate the width of Wales and I
say you can communicate in tension and
it's very profound and and it's very
evident you know we don't have to use
words and then like I shared with you
earlier yeah you you make that intention
by showing up every day with the same
group of whales and being respectful and
predictable so I'll be over here you
know in the distance you guys could come
see me if you want but I'll be over here
observing you and you just make yourself
predictable yeah they're very curious by
nature and I think we we take that away
from them you know because like you know
you know sadly like if we're only taking
a 10 day two-week holiday to swim with
whales that puts a lot of pressure on
whales because people and no operators
to because they're always having to
make compromises for everyone to have an
encounter and it's usually the Wells
just leave whoa yeah what are the
geographic locations that you go to I
for this body of work I they were all
done and in the Great Barrier Reef -
Great Barrier Reef Australia and then
the Kingdom of Tonga it's another place
yeah it's a great place for some millet
Outbacks
and um that is South Pacific alpha
Pacific
yeah it's by Fiji by Fiji yeah and those
two locations and the Eastern Caribbean
Caribbean island of Dominica which is
where that video was Dominique oh yeah
and and so then are you going out in a
boat that has like a bed in it and then
you're kind of just sometimes you're
sleeping in the bed and waking up and
then just those are the best but those
are really expensive yeah I usually get
a small boat and I sleep on shore it's
more economical oh and then you go out
everyday everyday in a small boat yeah
and if I do that I could I could stay
out sometimes for three months but if
I'm on a live aboard it's generally just
a couple of weeks and that's really
expensive oh why um because I have this
solo charter at solar charge hello a
solo charge charter charter yeah so I
have to book the boat for myself yeah
because it's there even it's even
scientifically proven that if you have
to me if you have more than one person
in the water with whales with Mickey
wells in particular yeah
don't know won't come as close yeah so
you have to be alone you know and and so
then so that it it makes sense then to
be so how long does it take you to get
from shore to the location every day oh
you know I mean sometimes sometimes we
could leave shore and find wells within
two minutes and there in 20 feet of
water yeah Wow you'll have a humpback
whale with 15-foot pectoral fins and
they're literally like in 20 feet of
water and they're pushing off the bottom
and walking around
sometimes it takes an hour hour to have
to go further out and find him but I
prefer shallow water just as a as a
photographer and I creative because
there's much more you can do with the
light and shadow in shallow water yeah
yeah yeah and the weights bouncing back
off of yeah you get their shadows I love
exploring that but also it's safer too
because whales like especially mother
calf pairs the moms love shallow water
because it's easier to protect the calf
from predators and other males males are
kind of you know bullies what okay so
there is these these are at the top of
the food chain though right yeah the the
toothed whales are at the top of the
food chain in particular killer whales
and sperm lows yeah they're they're
pretty high up yeah but their caps can
be hunted by like sharks they have to
protect him yeah I mean sharks killer
whales I'm not sure yeah I don't and
these were these whales eat
phytoplankton right no the the baleen
whales like hump actually plankton and
krill I think they're to see krill but
nn Cho Beason call real anchovies
plankton okay yeah I don't eat plankton
okay okay yeah but these guys eat squid
squid yeah whoa and they'll dive down to
a thousand feet or more and they could
be down for 45 minutes you know around
that to finding squid yeah wait so but a
thousand meters you said how they could
go to the deepest they've ever found a
sperm oil was 10,000 feet and it was
entangled in communication cable it died
that was many decades ago
yeah and and the the these they're
usually found anywhere from surface to
about 1000 feet is their normal for that
for that area of residing yeah yeah yeah
excuse me
yeah okay and then can we look at the
whale i Ronnie play there's a few of
them Oh perfect yeah perfect so we were
talking about liveaboards well this was
a liver board on the Great Barrier Reef
it was by chance they were this boat was
going somewhere they had a few days to
kill so I chartered them for five days
at a discount I was really grateful for
that we dropped anchor like seven miles
offshore and that well that you just saw
with the eye she showed up every day and
I the hurt yeah I would spend maybe six
to eight hours a day with her and she
would this is really close this is
probably four feet and she's the one
that's in that big photo that's the 30
foot photo that was on display in Tokyo
Wow
that's so yeah I probably spent 40 hours
with her and and the photo that's on
your wallpaper or in your desktop yeah
that's this is her left eye the one you
have on your who's the right also the
right eye Wow and think about that photo
I took it at 8 o'clock in the morning I
was waiting to be transferred to another
boat and she was swimming around the
stern so I just got in real quick grab
my camera and you'll notice above behind
her eye is black it's like there's like
a darkness to it that's my shadow of my
body just off to the side of RI so I
took that photo and then the dinghy came
to pick me up this small boat came to
pick me up and took me over to the other
boat and she followed me over and I
dumped my gear off on their deck grab my
camera whoop she was amazing that that's
yeah that's the one you have yes
we have synthesis of right that's the
right yeah and you said you can see your
shadow on this yeah my shadows over here
over here this yeah yeah she's coming
out of my shadow and the Sun is so low
it says it's such a little angle this is
an absolutely unbelievable yeah and you
can see they're just a really the fine
detail details on the wrinkles of this
like you said so this was shot from
about like six feet away
well maybe four feet yeah Wow they were
taken with Hausa blood made a 50
megapixel camera in 2000 I think it was
released in 2008 and and so this was
just happening as quickly as positive
soon as that camera was released and
someone made a housing for it I was able
to just cobble it together and go like
it and yeah it was 50 megapixel camera a
medium format camera yeah which was a
really big deal in 2000 88 yeah and then
and then Wow well I I just want to stay
on this for a little bit yeah there's
there's a couple things here you know
first is just what is going on in this
creatures experience in their sentience
yeah it's yeah it's crazy that they live
here
yeah and we live here and we don't
really interact you know and they're at
the mercy of how we live Wow
and I just I worry that they're gonna go
extinct you know yeah yeah always like
you you think about like some of these
wells like the sperm whale that I showed
earlier they have the largest brain ever
to know known to exist on earth they're
highly complex social animals they've
been around a lot longer than us
they've been shaping their communication
and culture for 7 million years and it's
much longer than us and it's a very
large brain they echolocate they can see
in your body they can see if anything's
wrong with you you know if you're female
and you're pregnant they can see the
fetus wall so they experienced the world
completely differently they could have
you know I don't know I don't know if
you call oral tradition that could be
passed on generation I don't know what
you would call that because they're
they're echolocating they don't vocalize
the way we do but that's something that
we may lose in our lifetime and we'll
never know what we've lost we'll never
have been well know the tools may emerge
to allow us to understand them to
measure their intelligence to understand
their culture and how they communicate
but it may be too late like we may just
lose that before we can understand them
and lose seven million years of that
culture it's yeah it's will lose a big
part of ourselves you know yeah Wow yeah
you're calm conservationists perspective
on whales is so important the way you
just voiced it I'm really happy that you
did and yeah just so gorgeous there's so
much to still learn and yeah they can't
we also so many species at the mercy of
the way we live we have yeah yeah we got
a prayer prioritize our ecology our
conscious living with nature you know
we've been saying that at 10% of every
single venture capital fund needs to go
to the Department of nature of
maintenance and around the world yeah or
or just just just make things more
efficient and empower us don't don't
make things highly inefficient and keep
us disempowered to make a to make a ton
of money you know I mean I think we're
at we're at a crossroads were the tools
are emerging to empower us and
don't things don't have to be
centralizing they don't have to be all
these artificial dependencies you know
we have to be optimistic yeah we have to
have hope we have to think intelligence
will prevail yeah it's weird it's like
energy and matter want to be conscious
yeah
and they want to sustain yeah they want
to be sustained right yeah and that's
potentially our role as stewards yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay
now you also had to train yourself in
scuba diving then as well well actually
free diving it's free diving
breath hold o breath everything is
snorkel everything store everything sir
oh yeah how long can you hold your
breath for about the longest I've held
my breath is five minutes Wow
and no no it's no big deal later however
long if you laid on the couch and try to
hold your breath as long as you could
you could probably do two minutes yeah
if you could do two minutes yeah yeah
you could do two minutes you practice a
little bit you can do two minutes I can
I could my one of my friends could train
you there's certified instructor in a
weekend you'll double your breath hold
time so you could technically hold your
breath for four minutes after a weekend
that's pretty cool
yeah it's our bodies are built for it
it's in our DNA yeah freediving wear it
were
we're aquatic yeah yeah until I can just
genetically engineer gills onto myself
oh yeah you're all set people working on
wonderful thing yeah yeah okay so what
some women so then you see free dive you
go you take you take of bertrise take a
breath and go down for two four or five
minutes oh not with the whales that's
just for fun so okay with the whales I'm
on snorkel and I generally try to do
everything at the surface and if the
whales really relaxed with me all exhale
so I'm negative and I'll sink thing I
won't even like kick or I'll just drop a
little bit and I'll start moving along
the side of their body and getting very
detailed I used to chug the camera on
its side with like what would be a 50
millimeter lens for a regular camera but
it was on a medium format so is it 80
millimeter but I would turn on its side
and go across the well but then I would
have these moments with wells that were
so accepting
that I like why don't I just drop down
and and do like well first I'll do the
top of the well the middle of the well
and then the bottom of the well all that
50 megapixel with this giant medium
format sensor and portrait lens and get
real detail like and get there closer to
their true colors and that was the last
biggest photograph I made was doing that
so that was some breath-hold work there
yeah and then you have to you have to
how do you in case the camera in right
there and water yeah so how do you
encase that in waterproof this is an
aluminum underwater housing it's my
favorite one it was made by UK Germany
and it's just such a simple housing and
it this is housing is made for the
fashion and advertising industry so you
know anytime they want to photograph
models underwater they need a camera you
know course housing how it originated so
because of that industry I was able to
grab this and go do that work with
whales you know I mean it's just really
crazy when you think about it that work
is not supposed to exist if you think
about economic you know business models
business plans and what's your
strategies and what's your return of
investment like return invest well more
people are gonna have a deeper
impression of what's out there
more conscious because this is yeah
we're talking like you know dot thousand
plus dollar and flights we're talking
you know boat rental every day you have
to take the time off work yourself to
pay your own rent you have to buy food
every day to you know you have to be a
nomad you don't even live anywhere yeah
yeah you just do it you just do it yeah
yeah so badass
yeah let's yeah if you have rent you're
not gonna do it yeah yeah
and then what happened until 2015 with
your father and the near-death
experiences you had oh yeah so you know
up until 2015 I had spent
three years full-time just raising money
to get back in the field with whales to
to print and mount my largest photograph
you know like a photograph that's taped
by 36 feet
it's like $70,000 to finished in museum
standards so it's a big responsibility
to make something like that so I never
could and I just thought you know that
was bothering me and I just came back
from my last museum show in Australia
and and went freediving I you know it's
training in Hawaii to go back in the
field and I spoke with my dad real
briefly and just just typical you know
father's sudden we go how you doing
conversation and then a couple weeks
later I saw him on the phone I was like
oh hey Dad and it was it was his wife
and he was in the hospital so I came up
to be with him he hit his head and was
unconscious and had a lot of internal
bleeding
you know in his brain and so I was able
to be with him for the last 24 hours
and and yeah and then a couple weeks
later maybe a month later I had a severe
reaction to a medication for myself and
had to be hospitalized and and I was
just laying in the hospital bed just
thinking what you know you know what am
i doing like you know I just
try it just yeah I just do an office
work and I'm just trying to fundraise
and I'm a creative like I wanna create
so you know I think losing my dad you
know just the way I lost my mentors just
lit a fire under me it's like you get
back and create and and even if it's
just you know outside your front door on
your patio you know learn to connect you
know and whales make it easy to connect
to nature they they pull you out of your
own head and you're you become present
you're present with them they're no
longer well is there there they're
amazing they're otherworldly when they
look at you like that but you know if we
can learn to feel that same presence
from a tree from a from a flower from
something growing out of asphalt you can
feel that same presence and you can feel
it from a shadow from the Sun as you
watch it move and so anyway that that's
when I made the decision just to create
every day mmm with what our whatever
tools I have and started with the Sun
yes and not thank us along the journey
to the Sun yeah I wouldn't even want to
begin you know
you know goes back to my childhood you
know the the paintings I made like this
one I don't know if you can see it if we
could zoom out and so the timing of your
slides are so weird
whoa I wanted to I painted this as a
child and and in my 20s this is a chunk
Wow with we go with watercolors I would
paint this is a well right here and
there's the Sun obviously so I was like
you know I I had a telescope and I
thought you know it was given to me by
my own in-laws to photograph Venus when
it transit in the Sun in 2013 I never
did anything with it and dusted it off
and and just started using telescopes
again and photographing the Sun and so I
tried to make that photograph and I
failed but then I had this telescope and
I thought well what else could I do and
I just started you know like allowing
myself to be a child again and not worry
about being original appealing to any
markets or just
whatever you know it's just like you
know I think there's something very
Universal about all of us you know
you'll see this when the moon is doing
something or the Sun is doing something
we'd like to line it up with something
on earth
I think it's an unconscious desire to
want to connect with the cosmos and to
something bigger than us and I think
it's innocent and and it doesn't have to
be original and so Universal and I
started with that with trees like you
know the Sun rising behind this tree and
this tree yeah I would photograph this
tree from seven miles away so the Sun is
like you know this big it's like it
would take up the whole frame and the
tree would be that big and you would
just explore that and that's where it
started but then I started to notice how
the light would work yeah this is this
is a photo that took 45 days to make so
the Sun would rise here as we approach
the winter solstice the Sun is moving
each day yeah all the way to here it was
cloudy over here but it lights up and I
just let it paint light every day yeah
this is not a one day was there 45 days
it's roughly 45 days yeah
so I started four weeks before the
winter solstice and on the cloudy days I
tried to pick those up after the winter
solstice so I'd go out on the days I
missed so I know exactly what degree the
Sun rose this roses 71 point two degrees
so I'll just go out which that's a wrong
degree for the winter but and I would
just pick it up on that day whoa yeah
you started you're connecting to to the
light and and also to into the void you
know like you think it connecting to
shadows
yeah what is a shadow a shadow it
reminds us of the void right its shadow
is the universe you know it's like
you're blocking sunlight void is the
default void is the nothingness is the
default and when you can make a shadow
it's like it's reminding you of that
nothingness most of the universe yeah
and how special the somethingness
is yeah
so that's the tree I was talking about
on Half Dome so I was waiting for the
Sun there's sunspots but so that's the
Trib and photographing for four years
but this is when that shadow cast would
happen and you know yeah and then the
the I love how you talk about the the
void and the nothingness is so prevalent
and then the somethingness is so the is
so little of it and that's right here
such an oasis in a way this is crazy
yeah and to you know view it that way
yeah and to take care of it this this
the Sun itself if we just quickly go
back to the previous image Iran just the
soot so are we are we seeing so this is
using infrared guitar sometimes use
infrared I either use infrared or
monochrome but more monochrome is that
is that just the is how do you add that
to a camera all for infrared you do you
can send out your camera for infrared
conversion whoa yeah there's a company I
use called life pixel and they do great
conversions yeah I use deep infrared so
what deep infrared does it catches the
wavelength of light I think is it 850
nanometers wavelength and so it throughs
the sky black so whoa our you know our
beautiful blue sky that that's one of
the things that reinforces separateness
this feeling that were separate from the
universe from the cosmos it's such a
beautiful lose you you know and the
infrared it does the same thing with
shadows it makes the shadows darker I
think and and when you could blend the
nothingness up here and you know pull
back the curtain of our atmosphere in
the in the daytime hours and then
connect it with the shadow here on earth
and then have something illuminated yeah
oh I may have some photographs like God
the nothingness in the cosmos and then
the shadow ah yeah I ended up the night
and then the Sun rising yeah yeah and
like our setting what's nice about this
too is like you know you could buy all
the equipment in the world you want
spend all the money you want but
sometimes you need filters that come
from nature so this is a very high thin
clouds
scatters light so it creates the
silhouette and otherwise if it was a
blue sky it would the whole scene would
be black you would just see from here to
here that's all you would see oh so he's
and run we zoom on the edge of the Sun
near the your I just do fall apart
because they get better at higher
elevations especially if you image them
over our photograph from over water but
you'll see turbulence that's all yeah so
then yes so then are these then flares
like you can see those and then those
are the sunspots those are sunspots so
you can actually start seeing sunspots
and you can see the the fact that it's
just constant fusion is happening and
you can see that along the edge you can
see it with a different filter that's
just atmospheric turbulence so it just
scatters the light where it mixes with
you know the sky like nothingness you
know the high energy of the Sun and then
almost the nothingness of the atmosphere
you reveals this turbulence and then I
have filters that let you see I think
they call it it's called I should know
all this but it's a chromis fear chromis
you can see all the detail the filaments
and the plasma and this is a white light
filter and it can let you see some
detail too interesting yeah okay all
right we'll move to the to the next one
now so that's a set up on my patio and
then I occasionally I'll take that I'll
take it to you so many at a place called
Tenaya Lake so that's what I was saying
if you can get to high elevations like
9,000 feet set it up over a body of
water like an alpine lake that air is so
stable hmm the sky is so black you know
and when you're in infrared or you know
imaging the Sun
yeah whoa that's a tree and the Sun
photographed from about seven miles away
so it's interesting that the Sun is
always the same size but the tree gets
smaller the further away you are let me
go back and this this is a revisiting my
work with it feeling this connection to
light that I have now like Jetta going
back to my old work and oh this is a
filter I was telling you about
and hydrogen-alpha so you can see that
kind of service Thanks it's a crazy
special surf this detail is crazy and
also how it you found the day the right
day of the year when the sun's rising
right right day right spot the spot is
only six by six feet if you step out of
it that this opening closes out it's
really cool and what's really cool is
you set up you set up two telescopes
because you could put each spire in
focus or like this they're like a couple
hundred feet apart and you also you can
get greater dynamic range and you see
the shadow of the two spires moving as
the Sun before the Sun emerges so as the
sun's about to emerge you'll see the
shadows moving and they just come up to
you and there's just something about
connecting two shadows moving like that
and they come up to you and they move
past you and then the Sun comes out I
don't know and quickly Ron can we just
go back walk for another moment I just
want to I just want to mention just a
couple things one of the things is just
on the on the one right after this one
the one that we were describing I forget
which one though is the Sun with the
crevasse so so then okay so then you see
again the sunspot yeah since but and
then you can actually start seeing it
what looks like all of those solar
flares
yeah there's solar flares so what you
see in what looked like filaments on
here I don't see any filaments there
might be one right there as the Sun
rotates those filaments will go to the
edge and become prominences so that's
when you see the flares you'll see these
giant flares and
yeah one so this happens a maybe one
couple days of the year when the sun's
rising just right there just this but it
only happens twice a year twice a year
yeah oh my god
all right yeah yeah and this was that
was this head I see you said you're
somebody yeah I love you so many because
you can stand in the valley and
especially in the winter time the Sun
will interact all day with trees and
stone yes and I mean just all day all
day all day just amazing and the colors
are amazing the shadows yeah yeah
although the air is really cold and
stable so yo yeah and then I think we
yeah I think we I guess another aspect
that I think we should cover with the
Sun is the amount of gratitude that we
can inspire by taking photographs of the
Sun and reminding us that it gives us
the source of life yeah yeah it's one of
the few things that are free and that
energy is free you know yeah and and you
know we were talking about this really
it is it's it's like this forbidden to
us to look at you know without some
tools and and I think we can look at it
when it's on the horizons oh yeah it's
safe well yeah I mean don't take my word
for it but but it generally is in the
end the evening in the morning I
wouldn't look at the Sun in the morning
as it rice but in the evening there's
more dust and more stuff in the
atmosphere so it could be safer oh yeah
everybody be careful yeah but using the
tools that I used to look at the Sun you
know you it it turns day into night when
you're looking at the Sun obviously this
guy goes black
it's Realtors reject so much energy so
you can see the surface and
you really start to see it for what it
is it's like it's just it's it's not an
afterthought it's not just this thing
that rises and sets and warms us up and
it's it's I realize how it's so much in
the background of our lives that we
don't really even think about it you
know and and
yeah I don't know how important it is so
it's been here forever having the life
yeah it changes you though when you when
you can really you don't need telescopes
either like I tell people like if you
could just you know like if you want to
I don't know I mean
just watching the shadows move like you
could be in a room and especially
towards the other day like you know
where I live I there's an oak tree out
my outside of my window and I could just
see the entire oak on my wall move and
if you just sit on your couch and if you
mean if you're ever in a situation it
changes you it's hard to believe but
just watching it move yeah right and
then and I'll be telling my wife I'll be
show do you see that and it's moving and
then it just it's gone yeah yeah you're
like wow yeah it's like where earth is
turning away those movements also happen
when the Sun shines through something
that breaks it up into a prism and then
you see the yeah the rainbow and then
you're watching it and then it's gone
it's gone yeah yeah the rainbow is there
and then it's gone you know these types
of things um okay let's let's just
mention this as well I think you've had
a couple times you mentioned this that
this this disconnection from the
universe is an illusion that we need to
stay closer to the source and that we
need to remind ourselves that it's
constantly here with us in front of us
what are the things that we can do in
order to remind us of that more often
being nature as much as we can yeah
and and it's a process you know like you
know for me like I think I've been in
nature more doing this work with the Sun
in the last four years
and it wasn't overnight you know I mean
if it's so subtle like you're peeling
back the layers and healing like it's a
lot of healing and you know I can't
emphasize that enough how much that can
change you
I feel really healed like you know I do
too
I was talking to Ron earlier you know
working working the weddings you know
and you know how we always are looking
outside of ourselves for completion
right we're always looking for that
person that's special someone to make us
complete or this thing you know or this
jaw like to be complete but nature helps
you yes just be complete you don't need
anything else we already are complete
yeah everything we need I think that's
my take a rolling stone sings about you
know all the all the crazy stuff I've
done you know the BASE jumping were that
transforms you and being with whales but
just not even the wells haven't done
that maybe just being with this this
watching the sunlight and being in
nature has taught me that it's you know
and I've been to therapy a lot you know
and it's really just the nature yeah
just the slow peeling back of the layers
and unpacking and just really yeah
sometimes you can even feel your
inflammation decreasing yeah things like
that yeah it's profound yeah and we also
teach us like this is obviously very
difficult to to to get into the hands of
sustainable people that will basically
getting your work into the galleries
that then help you potentially fund the
next artistic native endeavoring so it's
you said it's really expensive like
seventy thousand bucks to print a band
well yeah so how how has it been you
you're out you're giving a talk in
Boston right after this at the gallery
right so yeah Cape Cod yeah yeah
it's really challenging because that
division that separateness we feel from
nature is alive and well in the art
world the art world is really focused
primarily on the human condition and
nature is separate and on and I think
too in nature photography nature is
separate you know we often Photoshop
signs of humanity out of the photographs
so I think I think it's on both sides
but I don't yeah I feel like yeah it
hasn't really found a place to land yet
you know so
it is slowly finding homes you said yeah
we had a great show at the the dots
Museum of Art in Seoul Korea
last fall and that's a museum that
really aligns with my values and this
whole
this idea of separateness in art like
they're they don't see the human
condition and nature as two separate
things it's it's buried they're both
very much alive and one thing and and we
you know we did a group I did a group
show with them and a lot of the
photographers are from the Bay Area here
and our styles are very similar and the
way we connect is similar and it almost
was if it was just one photographer
liked it and only that the work conveyed
a singular presence like there's trees
wells and you know human-made objects
and it's just like there was like this
singular presence being a vote yeah oh
wait I hope the best for artists and
we're building that future where it's
easier for them to get the work into the
right places so that they could continue
going and funding more creative
endeavoring and making that more popular
for children to go into yeah do Brian
what are your thoughts on where we come
from before we're born do we come from
somewhere else into these other vehicles
the recent like being in nature again
like the thing I've thought about that
and I think yeah the thing is just
we come from nothingness and we go back
to nothingness and I think that makes
the somethingness of life very special
like you and I mean this right now very
special and that I mean that's that's
all I know
yeah that's all I can measure we can
measure oh you know this I we can
measure it and okay yeah so all right
all right
that could be yeah you could all be all
that is and yeah I could potentially
it's all the same thing
it's just a longing to understand and
connect this is very special
life is very special and yeah yeah to
help children really identify that and
yeah I love that
okay two more questions are we in a
simulation oh well well we don't know
right so and if we are insulation do you
want to know you know because if you if
you are confident we are then you could
end up you can up in jail you know I
don't know
yeah I
I think about that I don't have an
opinion it doesn't matter either way
it's a good answer and then what are
what do you thinks the most beautiful
thing in the world
okay connecting to ourself connecting to
yeah connecting to our self or our true
self and that's
as a divine self the wood is not a
oneness you know connect to ourself from
the next thing we know you know we sold
the devil yeah
connecting to our true self well it's
like when I had that experience of the
cosmos experience and self through me
all I was was just completely present
and and when you're completely present
you become the self-aware cosmos and I
don't know that's to me is the most
beautiful thing I love that Oh Brian
thank you so much for my pleasure on my
show the excel it's so fun we're sooo
probably five of your work yeah
appreciate your time yeah thank you
thank you thank you thank you everyone
for tuning and we greatly appreciate
we'd love to hear our thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking
also go and share more conversations to
your friends your family course people
online on social media about things like
the crazy epic creatures that we see in
our oceans like whales about the
coolness of photographing things like
our Sun and using light in these ways
and connect to nature more connect to
ourselves more talk about these things
more often with each other check out the
links in the bio to Brian Swarek studio
cosmos comm it's also his book beautiful
whale and his Instagram goal follow him
and spread his work around shout out to
Ron Vargas for producing and directing
thank you very much Ron and support the
artists entrepreneurs the creatives the
spiritual leaders around the world that
you believe and support them help them
grow check out our links in the bio
dissimulation our patreon PayPal
cryptocurrency links are down there
design cool merch and get paid do all
that and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into well
thank you so much for tuning in we will
see you soon
[Music]